if man makes himself a worm
he must not complain when he is trodden
on
experience without theory is blind
but theory without experience
is mere intellectual play
an evil person cannot be happy
for being alone with himself
he remains alone with the villain
live your life as though your every act
were to become a universal law
science is organized knowledge
wisdom is an organized life
all the interests of my reason
speculative as well as practical
combined in three following questions
what can i know
what ought i to do
what may i hope
we are not rich by what we possess
but by what we can do without
all our knowledge begins with the senses
proceeds then to the understanding
and ends with reason
there is nothing higher than reason
the busier we are the more acutely we
feel that we live
the more conscious we are of life
he who is cruel to animals becomes hard
also in his dealings with men
we can judge the heart of a man
by his treatment of animals
dare to know have the courage to use
your own intelligence
the reading of all good books is like a
conversation with the finest minds of
past centuries
marriage
is the union of two people of different
sexes with a view to the mutual
possession of each other's sexual
attributes
for the duration of their lives
rules for happiness
something to do
someone to love
something to hope for
give a person everything that he desires
and at that same moment he will feel
that this is not everything
cheerful expression on his face is
gradually reflected in the inner world
one looking into a puddle sees dirt in
it
the other stars reflected in it
the ability to ask reasonable questions
is a sign of intelligence
and discernment
character is the ability to act
according to principles
death is most afraid of those people
whose life
has the greatest value
a person can become a person
only through education
whoever has given up excesses
has gotten rid of hardships
humanity is the ability to participate
in the fate of other people
a person rarely thinks about darkness in
the light
about trouble and happiness
in contentment
about suffering and
conversely
always thinks about light in the
darkness
about happiness in the trouble
about prosperity in poverty
it is not thoughts that need to be
taught
but thinking
the more habits
the less freedom
in order not to cheat on the husband
the wife must change
and so that the wife does not cheat
the husband should not change
if you punish a child for what is bad
and reward for what is good
then he will do good for the sake of
profit
a wise man can change his mind
a fool
never
if a man is hiding his betrayal from you
then he still loves you
the life of people devoted only to
pleasure without a reason
and without morality
has no value
women make even the men
more sophisticated
what is beautiful is what you like
regardless of the meaning
thinking means talking to yourself
you should not fear being refuted
you should fear something else
to be
incomprehensible
he who fearfully cares about how not to
lose his life
will never rejoice in this life
children should be brought up
not for the present
but for the future
perhaps a better state of the family